i'm a [__] animal guys i'm an animal
and that coke at this guy's house turned
me into the savage that i was listen i'm
gonna tell you guys a story all right
i grew up in new york city in that area
and i know l.a and they got gangs and
everybody's tough
let me tell you something there's the
difference between talking about it
there's a difference between shooting
somebody in the [__] head
in boulder colorado i meant more [__]
killers that would take in those woods
they would take in those [__] woods
and boulder i knew a couple of vietnam
vets i had agent orange they were
missing half their [__] face
they even told me we don't shoot people
in boulder we just put peanut butter in
their pockets and tie them up to a
[__] tree in the woods
you come back the next day there's an
elbow and a tooth that's it
that's it those bears will eat right
[__] through you you're following me
and there's no santa monica police
shooting [__] animals up there those
cops don't give a [__]
it's like vegas what happens in the
woods stays in the [__] woods you
follow me
you follow him saying to you so there's
some [__] animals so i started
thinking about i knew these two [__]
vietnam vets that were up there that
were dying to kill people
they didn't even give a [__] you just
had to give these guys a reason to stab
somebody
so i'm sitting there going who can i get
to [__] help me with the scam
you know i already had the scam set up
in my head i got to set up a dealer
with another guy with a fake buyer i
already had the [__] move in my head
i had done it before
i was in colorado by myself who am i
going to [__] recruit
i didn't have that many days to get my
buddies out there plus my buddies stick
out
it took me [__] eight years to
accumulate you know to learn how to walk
in colorado
without sticking the [__] out when
you're from jersey is the way you talk
you don't mention pizza you know you
don't talk about bagels
you know these [__] morons come over
from new york i want bagels
what gives a [__] about a [__] bagel
guy there's blond [__]
walking around everywhere i'm roller
skates you can chase these [__]
and you're worried about a [__] bagel
you [__] momo
so i'm like who the [__] am i gonna get
to kill who who am i gonna get
to help me [__] take the drugs off
this kid this is a perfect stuff this
guy was a grape
you know listen when the drug scene came
up a lot of people thought they were
gonna become [__] dealers these guys
had no [__] experience selling stamps
you're following me they never even had
a paper route now they want to become
drug dealers and let me tell you
something
when it comes to life life is [__]
dirty when it comes to drugs and kilos
and [__]
it becomes a different situation and it
turns people into different things and
it's [__] scary
it's [__] scary and here i was
scaring the [__] out of myself
i'm sitting there going i'm taking this
[__] down i called one of my
buddies and he's like i can't make it i
work for the airlines i love to rob him
with him
this guy was crazy but he couldn't get
off he had a girlfriend so i had a
i had this guy in bowl that i worked at
the body shop with you know you got you
got these guys a guy that just tries to
be [__] cool but he's [__]
you know he had the goatee the tattoo
the leather jacket
the sports car the motorcycle the
pitbull
he had everything to be [__] cool you
know he hung out with motorcycle guys at
a strip club
when he sold you drugs it was like a
james bond movie he's like come here
and everything was you know and the guy
was half a [__] momo but he wasn't a
bad guy so i'm like maybe the tidwell
will help me his name was tidwell
he was a [__] idiot he had been the
navy for 10 years he was in san diego
now he was in love with a stripper
who danced at a nude place
are you ready guys she danced at a nude
strip club
and she was divorcing her husband so she
left the husband
and moved into tidwell's bedroom he had
to sleep on the couch
the reasoning was she was in love with
him but she wouldn't sleep with him
until she got a divorce because she was
catholic
you want me to say that again or did you
guys comprehend that
the first [__] shot she made this
[__] sleep on the couch why she went
into bed with that hot little [__]
body
and he slept on the couch like a [__]
you know
i'm i don't even know what because after
three nights i'm [__] something i'm
going in there i'm kicking the door down
i'm [__] her feet
something's going down you're not gonna
live here for a week for free you gotta
wash your dish you got to suck a dick
something's got to happen here [__] that
catholicism guilt i'm catholic dude
[__]
we'll write it off together i'll eat
your [__] and we'll [__] go to
[__] confession together all right
when he told me this i'm like i got this
[__] grape too
so the deal was set he was going to be
the the dealer he
i was going to be the middle man and
velo was going to be the victim
so we had to get the timing just [__]
right we had like a week to work with
because his trial was like in three
weeks or something where he had a plea
bargain
now there's an expression with a tangle
web we weave when we tangled to deceive
that played out that [__] day it's
november 18th
everything's set tidwell's parents had
money so his mother had property in
boulder this dumb [__]
and she had rental property in boulder
so he was going to use one of her houses
to set him up when he told me this i go
your mother has rental properties
and you're robbing [__] i got no family
i'm out here [__] robbing for myself
every day i understand that but you got
a nice [__]
whatever he goes just bring him over
here and we'll do the drug deal here
blah blah blah blah and we'll mug him
here
and the plan was we were going to mug
him he was the middle man he was going
to whip out a gun
i was an act surprised oh my god what's
happening here
he was going to put me against the wall
he was going to take velo's [__]
we were going to put vel in the [__]
car take him to the bus in arizona give
me 80 bucks and put him on the bus and
tell him never to come back
it was gonna look like he robbed the guy
his roommate that was my brilliant
[__] plan
that was it i was on the street stealing
for eight years and that was my
brilliant [__] plan
now i would have just picked the guy up
shot him
dragged him into the woods and taken the
coke and nobody would have known nothing
i would have had a conscience though i
would have [__] snapped you know i
would have ratted on myself
on facebook or some [__] i killed fella
in 87
oh please lord because you know
so with all that you know i'm like that
that was the [__] plan
so i called velo that night after work
we worked together on sunday and he goes
let's do it tuesday
i'll grab the coke randy's gone for the
whole day he won't come back till nine
he won't even realize what's going on
it's perfect
boom no worries monday you know i'm
thinking about this in my head i'm
looking at my girlfriend i'm looking at
my roommate i'm looking at my dog and
i'm like you know what
this is all great but i got to go with
the plan i got to do this
it's over i don't want to do this no
more i am what i am at that time i
couldn't break out of the [__] piece
of [__] mentality i was i was like [__]
i did all these things i'm never gonna
do nothing better
[__] it let me just rob this guy between
you and me i really wanted to shoot
somebody at that time i just wanted to
get it over with even if it was just in
the [__] ankle
even if it was in the leg i just was i
just wanted to [__] get it out of the
way
i had worked with all these guns i'm
like today's the day i had this nine
millimeter that i had from aspen i used
to sell guns
and i had it hidden in my front yard i
would never because i didn't want any
problems in the house you bring bad luck
so i put in the front yard in the bag
and i wrap it up with saran wrap and all
that [__]
i took it out and i put in the trunk of
the car and i picked up vela and i buzz
him
he goes come on upstairs and i'm like
[__] perfect i can case the place out
so i go upstairs he goes come in the
room he takes this [__] big bag of
blow out of the drawer
he gives me a bump and he puts it back
and he takes a rock out and he goes
let's do this rock
but when he goes to grind it up the
grinder's filled with coke
so he goes we'll just take this coke
rock and give it to tidwell as a sample
i go perfect you know it's nice and
shiny and he'll love it
so i see the [__] bag of coke i see
the grinder and i see a stack of money
in there
and he closes the desk and let's go and
as we're going
you guys know what a drop ceiling is
it's these [__] squares
and it's held by beams it goes that way
in that way and it has these little
styrofoam [__] things that you push
up
and you could hide [__] in the 80s and
70s and take your gun up there and
nobody would know
but you get [__] up and leave it
halfway open so people were like ah
somebody moved that [__] piece right
there it's on the way out he goes
that's where the coke is when we come
back would you just help me climb up and
we'll get in it's yours
and we'll sell it to your [__] buddy
so i knew the whole layout of the place
we're getting the [__] car boom
we're driving to tidwell's house as i'm
making a left on a canyon boulevard
you know when something makes you look
up like i just looked up and i seen
bctc a community correctional facility
and i just made a mental note and that
should have been right there
if that was today i would have [__]
made that u-turn and said we're going to
rob this guy but not today
because i seen that sign i'm real
superstitious but i said [__] it [__]
superstitious [__] going down
i'm gonna have a kilo tonight i'm gonna
snort half of it i'm gonna rub it all
over my body and my nuts out
i'm gonna find some chick at a bar to
lick it i'm gonna [__] have a blast
tomorrow morning i'm gonna go to denver
airport i'm gonna take a first class
flight i'm gonna snort the whole way to
[__] newark
i'm gonna go party with the devils and
i'm [__] going out that's it
i'm doing something that's it that was
my [__] brainstorm plan
i picked this [__] up boom he
shows me everything we get in the car
we're driving
we get to where [__] tidwell is i get
out we walk in
i introduce them i mean the plan was to
talk to the kids for a little while
soften them up and then pull the [__]
gun out till we go hold on one second he
turns around with a [__] machine gun
all right he's pointing it at me and him
and i'm like what the [__]
i'm like did well slow the [__] down and
he's like you too get on your hands and
knees and all this [__] and i'm like did
what the [__]
and he goes bring him in the other room
so bring him in the other room and he's
like are you in on this
and i got to tell you guys i felt like a
[__] mook
because i'm the type of [__] thief
that i want to rob you and look in your
[__] eyes if i want to rob you that's
how i was raised
so i'm gonna do a crime team i'm gonna
look at you i'm not gonna go in there
like a [__] way like oh my god what a
surprise i didn't like that [__]
so already i was starting to [__]
feel bad this isn't my type of [__]
game
my game was put the gun out let's take
them rob them that's said all his
charades and all this
[__] [__] was killing me he was
[__] killing me
so we take him into this room you know
we tie him up he goes tie him up i go
you [__] tie him up i ain't tying him
up you're robbing me too you got to tie
me up too
he tied him up and he doesn't tie me up
so the kid automatically knows he goes
how can you do this
i go dog you set yourself up you know
this [__] game how are you going to
show up at me with four pounds of
[__] coke
they gonna come at me with four [__]
pounds of coke i'm a shark
i'm a [__] shark how are you going to
show up like that it's 1987. look at me
i'm ready to [__] stab somebody the
plan was tibble was going to go back to
the house we give the guy the
the kids keys he goes back to the house
he's going to look to the house i don't
tell tidwell nothing where nothing is i
go tidwa i didn't go up there i don't
know what it's like just go through the
house
25 minutes comes back this [__] momo
walks in
and he says to me i went in there and
all i found was an
eight ball and sixty dollars
so i know i don't say nothing i go
really they double [__] crossed us
so i run into the room and i go villa
where's the [__] blow he went over
there wasn't that vela's like i don't
know what you're talking about vela knew
what i was
he played it off perfectly so i go back
out and i go you know what bro
i started thinking i go you know what
you're [__] me that was more [__]
blow
i was over there i seen the three
thousand he's like no there wasn't
there was only 60 bucks and all this
[__] i go you know what i'm out of this
i'm leaving you here with this [__]
idiot and you figure it the [__] out
he goes if you leave i'm gonna shoot you
i knew this guy was in love with that
dumb catholic girl
he wasn't gonna she couldn't wait to
give her the money for the divorce to
eat that little strip of [__] he
couldn't [__] wait you could see in
his eyes he was like hypnotized by him
so i go he goes i'm going to [__]
shoot you and him if you leave i know
this guy was a [__] half a wimp
i walked through the door and i go
listen bro just write it off
take him to the airport do what the [__]
you got to do with them you tried to
[__] me too i walked out of there i was
in a bunch now
i got a dilemma on me i got to do
something and i thought about that
[__] car
that gun in the trunk
i looked at the [__] car i looked
around the neighbor and i go if i go
back in there
i could shoot both these idiots take the
coke
and nobody would ever know nobody's in
this neighborhood it's not by [__]
the sticks they wouldn't find these guys
for a month
and by that time i'd be done with the
blow and bogota snorting with lawrence
taylor
you know what i'm saying i'm getting
down with somebody you know i'm showing
up with [__] four pounds i get
anybody to do blow with me at that point
who are you this is who the [__] i am
[__] open the door or you'll be
in there looking out windows by yourself